foreign
[Music]
I'm Star-Lord
I formed the Guardians
[Music]
met a girl fell in love
that girl died but then she came back
came back a totaled dick oh please he
left out some important information but
that is the gist of it
[Music]
that I wish you go
my sacred mission
is to create the perfect Society
I didn't want to make things perfect
we just hated things the way they are
[Music]
I want you all to know that I'm grateful
to fight beside my friends
incinerate them
foreign
until we found each other
are you ready for One Last Ride
we'll all fly away together
into the forever
a beautiful sky
[Applause]
whoever it was that you were in love
with it sounds more like her hers do not
bring me into them
knock it off what
just never noticed how black your eyes
were they were replaced by my father as
a method of torture he he picked a
pretty set
foreign
for quite a while
but no matter what happens next
the Galaxy still needs its Guardians
hello we come in peace
come on tracks seriously dude
foreign
[Applause]
we have been running
our whole lives
I'm done running
[Applause]
we'll all fly away together
one last time
into the forever
a beautiful
beautiful
[Music]
[Applause]
and they'll kill anyone who gets in our
way no not kill anyone kill a few people
kill no people kill one guy one stupid
guy who no one loves now you're just
making it sad
[Music]